[Musica]
avete mai provato a riprendere in mano
il vostro curriculum a rileggerlo ve lo
chiedo perché c'è una parte del
curriculum di ognuno di noi che è uguale
che abbiamo in comune tutti quanti una
parte che poi si ricollega una storia su
John Lennon e Pink Floyd che vi racconto
dopo Comunque tornando al nostro
curriculum studi impegni lavori
riassunti in poche pagine e magari anche
voi nel rileggerlo Avete provato la
sensazione che per quanto possa essere
ricco ed esperienze il curriculum il
vostro curriculum non restituisce mai
l'immagine che abbiamo di noi stessi ci
siamo per davvero e sapete perché perché
ci concentriamo a leggere le righe dove
abbiamo scritto qualcosa le nostre
esperienze mentre non guardiamo quella
parte del curriculum che nascosta tra
una righe e l'altra tra un'esperienza e
l'altra non guardiamo quella parte del
curriculum quegli spazi bianchi che
nascondono i nostri insuccessi i
progetti mancati i progetti naufragati
le strade interrotte le porte che
abbiamo trovato chiuso non siamo
riusciti aprire o le porte che ci sono
state sbattute in faccia ecco se
provassimo a mettere in fila tutti
questi mancati traguardi formeremo un
altro curriculum un curriculum in
parallelo un curriculum a prima vista
nascosto un pericolo in filigrana
chiamiamolo come ci pare eppure quello
quel curriculum parallelo e il
curriculum più importante che abbiamo
ognuno di noi perché col curriculum che
custodisce che conserva le difficoltà
che hanno fatto la differenza nella
nostra vita che ci hanno reso quello che
siamo che le hanno dato spessore
un curriculum così lo abbiamo tutti
quanti Anch'io ne ho uno ma non parlerò
di quello vorrei invece raccontarvi la
storia di una ragazza di 25 anni
del suo curriculum in parallelo di come
lei ha reagito di fronte a una porta che
le è stata battuta in faccia siamo negli
anni 50 Rosanna questo è il suo nome
aveva appunto 25 anni si laurea e dopo
anni passati sui libri vuole fare il
prefetto si iscriva a quel concorso
Eppure viene esclusa da quel concorso
non perché il suo voto di laurea non
fosse sufficientemente alto non perché
lei non fosse preparato viene esclusa
perché nel 1959 in Italia le donne non
potevano fare concorsi per accedere alle
carriere direttive nella pubblica
amministrazione
perché una legge di una quarantina
d'anni prima e glielo impediva Eppure
all'università Rosanna le avevano
insegnato che la Costituzione sancisce
che c'è l'uguaglianza tra uomo e donna
Eppure la Costituzione sancisce anche
che ciascun cittadino dell'uno e
dell'altro sesso può accedere agli
uffici pubblici senza distinzione in
condizioni di uguaglianza Eppure Pensate
un po' ad insegnargli queste cose c'era
stata non uno qualunque ma una persona
che aveva contribuito a scrivere la
Costituzione un padre Costituente un
giurista un professore Costantino
mortati Di fronte a quell'esclusione
così Rosanna va proprio da lui ma a
bussare alla sua porta gli racconta
quello che era accaduto lui la Ascolta
la lascia parlare alla fine le chiede ma
queste cose le stai raccontando al
professore o all'avvocato e le dice
all'avvocato perché vorrei che tu mi
difendessi Lui accetta l'incarico e così
portano quella questione in tribunale
per ottenere giustizia per ottenere
quello che il parlamento aveva tardato a
fare una legge che garantisse le pari
opportunità tra uomo e donna
la questione finisce in tribunale e da
lì fino in Corte Costituzionale
e la Corte Costituzionale Allora era
fatta di uomini e basta si riuniscono
discutono dibattono alla fine si devono
arrendere la norma che aveva fatto
escludere Rosanna da quel concorso con
una norma contraria e la costituzione e
contraria al principio di uguaglianza va
abrogata e il Parlamento ne deve fare un
altro era il 13 maggio del 1960
l'anniversario in questi giorni Ecco il
Parlamento dovette approvare una norma
per disciplinare l'accesso delle donne a
tante carriere a quella in prefettura ma
anche i magistratura nella carriera
diplomatica e dopo qualche anno anche
nel mondo militare pensate senza quella
ragazza di 25 anni noi non avremmo avuto
tanto per darvi un'idea Samantha
cristoforetti comandante della stazione
aerospaziale internazionale non avremmo
Margherita Cassano primo presidente
della Corte di Cassazione
non avremmo Elisabetta Belloni fino a un
paio d'anni fa a capo della diplomazia
italiana e ora dell'intelligence non
avremmo Gabriella Palmieri a capo
dell'avvocatura Generale dello Stato
quella che difende lo stato non avremmo
avuto fino a due anni fa Marta cartabia
primo presidente della Corte
Costituzionale proprio l'organo che
diede ragione a Rosanna e che ancora ad
oggi è guidato da una donna Silvana
Sciarra Ecco Tutto questo grazie a una
ragazza di 25 anni
che non si è voltata dall'altra parte
che ho fatto in modo che le donne che
sarebbero venute dopo di lei
avrebbero potuto fare e avrebbero potuto
percorrere strade che desideravano
e tutti È consentito a tutto il paese di
fare un enorme passo in avanti
e veniamo ai Pink Floyd a John Lennon ve
l'ho detto Forse qualcuno di voi ha
avuto la fortuna di ascoltarli dal vivo
intendo io ho avuto la fortuna di
ascoltare e di vedere i Pink Floyd
partiamo da John Lennon 1971 John Lennon
incide una canzone
può risolvere Epic Christmas o Happy
Christmas War is Over una canzone
pacifista contro la guerra del Vietnam e
per rendere ancora più incredibile il
messaggio di pace al suo interno
utilizza un coro di bambini dai 4 ai 12
anni il coro della comunità di arlen
probabilmente a loro il quartiere più
povero di New York
e decidi inaspettatamente generosamente
di inserire proprio sulla copertina del
disco la foto di quei bambini di quel
Core il loro nome in modo da far
arrivare anche qualche provento dalla
vendita di quei disco anche la loro
famiglia è così che i bambini una volta
diventi tutti i grandi avrebbero potuto
scrivere sul loro curriculum non in
parallelo ma in quello vero di aver
fatto parte di questa esperienza otto
anni dopo un salto in avanti invece nel
79 i Pink Floyd
incidono l'album che probabilmente li
consegna la storia della musica rock
internazionale Another Brick in The Wall
proprio per questo brano decidono anche
loro di ingaggiare un coro il coro di
una scuola di musica di Londra ma
nessuno di quei ragazzi ha potuto
scrivere sul proprio curriculum di aver
fatto parte di questa esperienza perché
Pink Floyd non registrano alcun modo il
loro nomi loro dovette aspettare una
nuova legge in Gran Bretagna e fare
cause e ottenere quei diritti e Roger
Waters non la prese benissimo perché vi
racconto questo perché il senso di
questa storia Certamente ascoltare buona
musica semplicemente dal vivo e quindi
andiamo ai concerti Ma poi c'è un altro
elemento anche se non ce ne accorgiamo
con le nostre scelte con le scelte che
facciamo ogni giorno abbiamo la
possibilità di incidere positivamente o
negativamente nella vita degli altri di
chi c'è attorno pensate a come ha inciso
il John Lennon nella vita di quei
bambini pensata a come inciso la scelta
di Rosanna Oliva nella vita di intere
generazioni di donne in questo paese che
hanno potuto fare quello che lei era
stato precluso ecco quando ci fermiamo a
guardare il nostro curriculum Quando
guardiamo il punto del curriculum della
nostra vita dove siamo arrivati pensiamo
sempre che siamo in quel punto Grazie
anche a quello che ha fatto qualcun
altro o direttamente con un consiglio
con un passaggio ma anche molto più
spesso con una battaglia che ha fatto di
Semmai di cui non conosciamo nulla siamo
lì anche grazie a quella battaglia di
cui noi possiamo godere soltanto i
frutti e semmatico non ne conosciamo
nulla qualcuno che non si è portato
dall'altra parte qualcuno che ci
consentito di non ripartire da zero di
non ripassare dal via come un gioco
dell'oca qualcuno che si è ritenuto a
parte di una comunità e non
necessariamente per bontà d'animo
generosità ma semplicemente perché in
una comunità Siamo tutti sulla stessa
barca e bisogna remare tutti perché è
senza remare si la barca si ferma e
prima o poi si affonda sempre tutti
insieme Ecco è il modo in cui noi
vediamo noi stessi all'interno della
comunità quello che fa la differenza se
noi ci vediamo come spettatori che si
limitano a osservare come vanno le cose
Oppure se ci riconosciamo come attori
comprimari che possono provare a
cambiare le cose realmente che possono
provare a fare dei passi in avanti anche
se non raggiungeranno dei traguardi ma
potranno portare il percorso a un punto
più in là che potrà essere ripreso da
chi verrà dopo di noi questo vuol dire
fare parte una comunità Questo vuol dire
fare parte e fare dei passi in avanti
spesso passi in avanti sono stati fatti
nella storia di questo paese da persone
da donne e da uomini di cui non
conosciamo il nome nomi e cognomi a noi
sconosciuti a cui non associamo un volto
Eppure hanno fatto la differenza perché
fare la differenza è possibile se siamo
tutti impegnati a fare la differenza
sapete chi l'ha detto un uomo un cognome
che probabilmente non diverrà nulla
James Wood un ragazzo di 21 anni che
negli anni sessanta nel profondo sud e
segregazionista degli Stati Uniti decise
il primo nella storia di iscriversi
all'Università di quel paese
la legge glielo consentiva nessuno prima
di lui l'aveva fatto dovette scortare la
polizia per farlo entrare dentro il
campus tra i fischi degli studenti
bianchi che non volevano uno studente
nero in quel Campus lui si iscrisse dopo
un paio di mesi i campioni università
andò all'università del Michigan e
ancora oggi nel suo curriculum alla
parte più importante è quella riga
Bianca dell'università della labama lui
aveva 21 anni ed è stato in grado di
fare la differenza come aprendo gli
occhi alla sua comunità e facendogli
fare un passo in avanti Ecco fare un
passo in avanti vuol dire non vuol dire
necessariamente essere grandi avere
esperienza non dipende da quanti anni
abbiamo non dipende da quanta esperienza
abbiamo fatto non dipende dal luogo dove
siamo nati non dipende dal lavoro che
facciamo né dal ruolo che ricopriamo
fare la differenza in un paese vuol dire
giocare le carte che la vita ci ha dato
in mano cercando di rendere migliore il
pezzetto di mondo che noi siamo
calpestando la nostra famiglia La nostra
scuola il nostro lavoro la nostra
università La nostra città il nostro
paese Ecco noi qui ed ora siamo in
questo paese in Italia e abbiamo tutti
la possibilità di rendere un paese
migliore come vorremmo che fosse senza
essere semplici osservatori o spettatori
un caro amico scomparso troppo presto
diceva che la speranza David sassoni
diceva che la speranza siamo noi siamo
noi quando non chiudiamo gli occhi
quando non alziamo muri quando
Combattiamo contro le giustizia Ecco la
possibilità che abbiamo è fare dei passi
in avanti passi in avanti per rendere
migliore come vorremmo che fosse questo
paese per fare in modo di cambiare il
paese e non cambiare paese Buon Cammino
a tutti